lorsqu'on arrive à de brillants ce sont
les épaves de voitures qui souhaite la
bienvenue et s'est assise du nord au sud
de l'île où les vhs servent eux denis
haras occupent les places de parking
empoisonnent les résidents alors là nous
avons des batteries au nous avons de
l'eau stockée d'auxilia ya certainement
dix de moustiques nous avons de lui des
bouteilles du plastique descendu en fait
tout a été mélangé ils ont pris
carrément le véhicule pour une benne à
ordures donc ça arrive très souvent ça
fait 20 ans que je fais ce métier ça
fait tôt que j'enlève des véhicules tous
les jours ça n'a jamais changé dans les
semaines qui viennent 250 vaches u
seront retirés des quartiers est envoyé
à métal noble où ils seront traités
l'opération coûte plus de 31 mille euros
à la ville la seule de martinique avoir
un service dédié
les communes ne sont pas responsables de
l'enlèvement des vh eu un décret d'avril
2010 est exigent la création d'une
filière de traitement des épaves
notamment à la charge des constructeurs
automobiles une obligation demeuré
lettre morte
j'ai pris la tâche des protégés de prix
la tâche d'idéal qui sont en charge de
ce dossier qui m'ont assuré qu'ils les
avances sur la mise en place d'une
filière d'évacuation de 6 à 10 h u mais
en attendant que la fille ça fait neuf
mois que le décret est sorti on n'a
toujours pas de résultats et moi j'ai
décidé d'enlever ces véhicules qui est
sont une source de pollution mais qui
sont également un disque en matière
sanitaire convoité hausse à mettre des
voitures l'un des leviers huacho tout le
monde fait c'est tout
tu es quand revenant eux sont pourtant
bien retrouver et verbaliser 500 + 130
euros damende soit quatre fois plus cher
qu'un dépôt de véhicules ada 15